[Music]
another day another ton of deliveries
but for this UPS man things are about to
get special for cyd Perrin deliveries in
this rural area outside Tampa Florida
usually mean long detours today though
she has a high-tech helper CID can load
a package into this basket in the roof
of her truck and then with a couple of
taps she can launch it like Airwolf from
its secret mountain lair instead of
having to take a winding road through a
blueberry farm CID can just get on with
her next delivery while the octocopter
does its thing dropping your package
autonomously it weighs just 9.5 pounds
and it can fly for thirty minutes it can
use GPS for that autonomous flying where
it's allowed by the time SIDS done the
drone is - and it just comes home to
roost moveable roof rack likes LEDs on
the roof of the truck lift and grab the
drone and position it perfectly so that
it can plug in and charge from the
trucks onboard power this is the more
realistic future of drone deliveries
they're not going to replace trucks with
fleets of drones leaving faraway
warehouses but they've supplement bans
UPS calculates that cutting one mile
every day from the route driven by each
of its 66,000 drivers would save 50
million dollars a year although this is
just a one-off demonstration and it
needs a lot of steps including
regulatory approval before it becomes a
reality other companies are working on
similar ideas this is the Mercedes
vision van it's very obviously still a
concept
so for now it will be smiling drivers
like sid ringing your doorbell to let
you know you have a package but one day
you could be listening out to that
puzzle Boudreau
[Music]